hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm here with yamimash hello I'm eme
mash hi I'm ash and we're playing a rage
game and I'm just gonna rap no you do
that nama why I can't oh I'm crouching
now okay so this is for team working
such right this is this is bloody
trapline yes bloody a lot of fun a
fairly is a rage game got ya know I'm
supposed to be the expert this game and
it seems that I'm already doing quite
bad yeah yeah me matches played a we're
gonna get through this have you keep
killing me damn it come in here if I can
get past the first level I would be very
happy okay okay okay alright
oh I didn't even get over there no no I
can just go off the screen and boy nice
ah damn it
okay so anyway this is a rage game of
sorts that yamimash has played before
he's gonna guide me through this
wonderful level there you go I go easy
he starts off really easy but I would
say after maybe two or three more stages
oh damn it gets it gets pretty tough
okay yeah sure whatever you say this
seems like stupid easy I don't even know
just why mark and will so will to you
you won't even understand how this good
I don't know I've played some pretty bad
games before or some pretty tough game
hey I don't want you to impress everyone
by finishing the level it's the point of
two player just so that we can get in
each other's way that others to this we
just kill each other and then laugh at
each other is one of us complete
levelling cetera I know your spine Otis
you're spastically crouching are you
just trying to make sure that I don't
get a chance to oh wow well so to crouch
underneath this thing you try that Oh
surprise oh very nice reminds me a
picture of like Super Meat Boy
and what was the other I played in
another game like this I'm just rushing
through everything seems easy right now
for you I suppose yeah is there any
other part ah yyy a me why would you do
this to me that wanted to show off a bit
deliver hey hey yeah stop that why do we
wait you try and kill me
oh this is this is we're supposed to
work together in this yeah I don't see
any point in doing any sort of teamwork
when when you're just out here to murder
me well for a little bit because I've
gotten enough satisfaction hey God I'm
gonna get through this don't don't go
don't go over yet I'm gonna get this I
think oh oh your blood on the wall oh
you're bad how did I get over this first
one then watch don't you dare touch that
I'm gonna get you closer no I've got to
get it
me and my blankie are gonna go so far to
the end there we go can I get this oh
okay just go just go man scope haha I
will admit it was fun watching you die
oh really really oh god after all of our
years of large values a fudge all of our
years of fudge-packing you know oh oh
yeah so what what's it like having a
girlfriend oh wow let's just say
brilliant okay brilliant Wow actually
the hanging bar I burned up that's so
British of you to say it's brilliant
oh wow there's a long maggot involved
don't think you can't do and I suppose
there's always the pros in the car I do
the level hang on I'm getting there how
do you
Bert yeah I've heard you've got many
girlfriend applications yeah yeah I
still get girlfriend applications on the
regular okay well I suppose one of those
will stand out and a pal ah I just got
to get a harem
well that is that what you're gonna call
her Gilly player ha ha ha
girlie flier that's what my girlfriend's
name would be Oh
both yes girlie fire yes ladies you
could become the next girlie flier send
in your applications now remember to
have a three by or wasn't with some
approval of the four by six four by six
of your top and boobies what is this
black thing and sends measurements
always shoot bullets to you why why is
that a thing what the the bullet thing
yeah why Wow come on I just get the
impression that's some sky yeah like
Super Meat Boy in a way somebody's
probably out to kill us and they've set
traps everywhere it's almost as if this
game is called bloody trap Lane Raj I
did the level why I'm trying here Yami
I'll give you more of a chance oh no not
the lasers Oh God just scream for those
lasers no it's just a bullet if your
homes in on you it's really annoying
okay watch this first try man Oh God
first try man oh no bro dodges whoa oh
oh hey your moments of glow you have
that one but you're not gonna do it
secretly I was too pro this entire time
except for that you've been just keeping
it like we've how like all your skill
yeah on the down low oh why that's how
you do it in Britain Land Britain oh the
old times like that over in Britain land
Oh Oh Wingardium live you saw
Simonian gee
oh we don't sound like that
ah but oh it's very much over the top no
way that's not how you all talk no I
suppose very very posh old people may
sound similar to the regular person no a
bunch of old people over are at a pub or
just like oh it was nice on some
crumpets oh no no oh I just like
watching you die yeah
this feeling is mutual I'll let you have
Hey look I don't see what happens when
you don't get in my way Yami
I'm fine you try again oh I will
whoa look at me oh what's this Oh - bro
[ __ ] a nice day
this is how you what I disappeared what
happened I don't really know what just
happened
be impressive just is your girlfriend in
the other room watching you watching you
fail turn me on my laptop she's on your
thanks sure I've had all the secrets and
important stuff and folders mister the
secret porn stuff oh oh oh I'm so sorry
yeah I'll be mashed at your giant porn
collection it's almost fell she will
never know unless she watches this video
but I'll tell her not to yeah it's
because I'm I'm a horrible person then I
know one no one watches my videos yeah
why don't you just start playing your
giant porn collection it's not like your
forklift big I'm saying literally your
porn collection is all about giant women
just big Amazonian types yeah you can
never go wrong with a bang yeah the
kinds that can crack your skull open
between their thighs Oh what so they
giant has a muscle
oh they're giant in terms of both
they're like nine feet tall I've seen
your collection before it's very very
thorough I would never go out with a
woman that can actually just beat me up
why there's something intimidating about
that ah come on we can't make that jump
that jump is impossible I can't even get
past the two spikes hang on
way to get this up all right this is how
you do it monkey watch it
tell me oh do tell me yamimash how is it
that I do that I fall down here is that
oh okay it didn't seem to work it's way
too much blood all this level for my
life not even that far in the game this
is supposed to be odd I made this before
I swear oh I think the point of two
players is just to double the amount of
lives you throw at this level before you
finally give up nine lives not these
cats these are cats I don't know these
are the cats exactly white cats not even
you don't jump on the spike yamimash you
got to get over the spike I've done this
multiple times now and I'm sorry what
I'm trying to channel my inner protists
so please just hobby shop shop shop got
this oh yeah so good I even kept quiet
for you as well
thank you this is where we died there
how do you double jump no I'm so sure
hahaha
think you just think so maybe we got to
bounce off I want each other to get up
there maybe that's what has to happen
well teamwork we actually gonna work we
the only stipulations that we both got
to get over there okay okay hang on I'll
go first okay ready my face in yoga crap
[Music]
you screwed it up yummy I didn't know
about the double chip
I don't either oh wow we didn't even get
me the controls for this game how do you
play this before I've done like a 20-pot
series part sir so you're going this
before you know how to get past this
you're just gonna telling me no I
haven't played it in so long
okay hang on I got I'm gonna get this
okay you just don't jump
oh you don't tap up when you're on the
thingy and then you you you don't you
tap up once you're at the top you tap up
later that's that's the point
yeah yeah thanks to me see who is the
best that's what she said oh yeah sexual
innuendos or not enough what you can
never have enough to be honest I thought
we agreed that this is gonna be me doing
good and then I'm laughing at you the
whole video I know such terms
Oh giant fist spoke about this we did
not and if it did happened to be spoken
about you spoke in that weird British
accent that you speak in and I didn't
understand any of it oh I see
screwball day we both made it okay I'm
ready good at this level so I'm gonna do
this first time watch ow
i ki jai light and I got this his double
jump yeah Oh bullets ah I got this uh
yeah it was a good job was was it good
was it wasn't God made it just one of
you will you wait no knew you're so good
at this level
hey God I better get it back there it
okay hey hi you distracted me
you just killed me come out of this
chair to screw you up now I'm that's all
I'm gonna do hey I got this I got this
when you have your cap crouches it keeps
blinking like that so win cuz I'm the
nice kitty
and you're the evil kitty just just get
all right fine plenty more okay oh good
all right here we go let's do this
doesn't this music remind you of the
Final Fantasy Europe yeah Final Fantasy
fight music and like Final Fantasy 7 I
think yeah the I don't know kind of
minds me of that I don't put the game in
ages maybe like a yeah you were on it
you pushed me off I saw it every one
side no more crying for his bottle
yamimash turns reflecting all Oh anyway
this is supposed to be a bench mode
where you work together then there's a
race mode where we race each other which
I would win definitely yes sure and then
there's a deathmatch Oh where we kill
each other
I think more or less in this is pretty
much all three of them fuse because we
just keep killing each other and racing
so huh oh yeah how'd that happen
the first forward so that I do not die
okay I got this I got this I got this I
got this wait wait wait wait wait
oh okay okay you got this I got this
hi all right who's the one that has been
finishing four levels in you you well
you stay then you see what I watch this
I'm watching I'm waiting for something
amazing
oh oh yeah you got it oh oh that was
look you know what I said that I played
this game um well let's just say I'm
very good at it
all right anyway I'm all that time for
my part okay so thank you all so much
for watching if you want to see more
yamimash is gonna have another part of
this continuing where we left off here
on his channel so check the link in the
description below or click on his
beautiful face over there it'll probably
take you to it or somewhere else
straight but either way there's more to
come check out yamimash the channel so
thank you yeah be mash and thank you
much for having me on
uh-huh and buddy what were you gonna say
some young man I'm just gonna say that I
beat the level oh okay all right thank
good for you okay so thanks again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]
okay okay so
oh that's a that's
wanna stay okay all right fine